you open the show with your new single
had it was amazing yeah I'm it was
amazing uh it's been a long time in the
making and I feel like a proud dad
tonight we're proud of you it's the 20th
anniversary of your self-titled album
the one that made you really an
international crossover what's something
you learn along the way 20th anniversary
of Mark Anthony you believe that no no
no I'm uh
you just whose enlighten me accident
so you're the Godfather sauce for easy
and you learned a lot along the way
what's something you want to pass on to
the next generation something you wish
you knew back then what I would say is
is uh you know we take on this
responsibility and what I would say just
be responsible Oh
fulfill your commitments respect and and
and you'll be here for a while enjoy the
fruits of your labor right yeah yeah
that that's a given but but but as far
as advice is concerned these days you
know there are all kinds of ways for
these kids to get attention for the
wrong reasons what I would say is just
be responsible know that you're taking
on a commitment to represent your people
you need to respect it and just have fun
never never never stop feeling that
you're lucky and and just honor that the
honor honored people's commitment to you
as well real quick you brought your
friends along the way you got Will Smith
a preemie alone Westone nomination this
year what do you think of that oh man
you know there's so much for us to see
together you know the is just the
beginning
I'm I'm proud that he was recognized
again we just had fun all all the way
this is just a blessing it's a it's a
byproduct oh just let me do good working
for the right reasons it's Will Smith
the next Latin music crossover dude he's
he's gonna take all our jobs
leave it to will to take over the land
in the sea congratulate you
[Music]